alright alright and you are loved who is
this fine gentleman I'm speaking with
right here nice nicely tell me your your
other things as far as your role and
involvement with the title nice right
nice we have that authentic feel love it
love it love it alright so as far as
this building stuff like that tell me
about visitin also has from the
perspective of someone that's never
played any Fist of the North Star Game
already nice nice but now it's seeing
some gameplay footage I saw some
throwbacks to some classic system with
some Sega systems inside that footage
can we confirm that uh maybe like a
Saturn or a dreamcast or an old Sega
system might be hidden within the game
okay I paired up fair enough there are
farm differences between the last title
what new things can we expect from
cachoeira what can we expect
I mean as far as like this iteration of
the franchise any new things that you
can expect
all right she's a fine gentleman that
we're speaking to you like nice great
games
gotcha we call an alternate timeline oh
okay
nice really
okay okay
so this we've taken a different approach
from previous series like gotcha gotcha
who's that who's that development team
[Music]
we can we can Barton Wow I was expecting
over-the-top Venice is insane that's
what we need as we need so as far as I'm
wearing it right now so our development
as far as baby um release upper setting
also you have a day this
[Music]
Wow so we getting it soon when it's not
too far
all right in platforms nice nice looking
forward to it
huge fan of the series it's in the
building yard thank you so much for your
time that's right let's check out the
hashtag dog you're already dead
it's out here man check it out Fist of
the North Star lost paradise a little
podcast proof